um who did you play i heard that you did
greece okay i did yeah i did greece and
fiddler on the roof in high school and
i was never cast in the lead role ever
so
for kids out there watching don't worry
if the teachers don't choose you
you could still successful
musical comedy franchise of all time
like you still could
i'm the light at the end of the tunnel
so i in greece i was never
um cast as one i wanted to be like jam
that one that did like brush up brush
brush oh i wanted to be rez yeah well
that was a good role too i just didn't
even set my sights that high and then
and then
so i didn't get cast because they said i
was too young only the girls in year 11
can um can be the lead roles you have to
be in the chorus
and so me and my friend we'd sit there
like this watching all the main girls
so in greece we'd sit there and we'd
watch the main girls and we'd be like oh
imagine if like something bad happened
to them like
then maybe we could go on because we
know the songs we could just go on
and then we're standing backstage at
rehearsals and a big television monitor
falls on us that literally falls on our
head like it was really dangerous
and then we never wished ill upon
another performer
ever again yeah that is yeah
um and then fitter on the roof that was
my first taste of fame
actually because i fell from the roof so
in that photo you can see i played the
ghost character called from
sarah there i and i was like this ghost
and i descended from the roof
it was a very big entrance yeah helped
develop very pink
yeah and i came down and there was a
technical difficulty
because it was a high school production
wasn't that safe so and i
fell from the roof went splat onto the
stage everyone thought i was dead
i became a local celebrity because of it
and i still was back out on stage the
next night showman rocking it out yeah
yeah yeah i fell i sprained all my ribs
and my
wrists um but luckily was fine want more
fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure